[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
[Musique]
la crise sanitaire du covid est
partiellement terminé mais elle a laissé
des traces sur la santé mentale des
adolescents
[Musique]
troubles alimentaires et gestes
suicidaires sont en augmentation chez
les 13 17 ans le covid nous
a montré comme ça des adolescents qui
peut-être n'auraient pas décompensé
s'il y avait pas eu ce moment un peu
hors temps un peu ORL lieu qui a été le
confinement
pourquoi les jeunes générations
ont-elles été autant touchées quelle
solution apporter c'est le thème de ce
nouveau numéro d'état de santé
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cet état
de santé question aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
que le covid a laissé comme trace sur
nos ados nos adolescents t'intéressant
de vérifier si le choc qu'ils ont subi
de l'enfermement du confinement à
laisser des traces ou non et si oui
lesquelles est-ce que le retour à la
normale aussi a eu un effet sur leur
psychologie toutes ces questions on va
les explorer avec vous on est très
heureux de vous recevoir bonjour
Philippe Duverger bonjour vous êtes
professeur psychiatre chef de service au
CHU de danger vous avez signé un certain
nombre de livres je voudrais avec vous
parce que c'est intéressant les titres
le premier c'est la petite voiture rouge
au fond de mon tiroir c'est quoi ça la
petite voiture rouge au fond de mon
tiroirs
et c'est un des petits garçons qui m'a
laissé sa petite voiture qui est
toujours au fond de mon tiroir et pour
montrer que finalement toutes ces
histoires restent longtemps dans la tête
très belle évocation il y a aussi mes
parents sont fragiles l'amitié à
l'adolescence voilà c'est le dernier
opus si je finir votre dernier ouvrage
très important l'amitié évidemment c'est
c'est fondateurs pour eux c'est il y a
tout dans l'amitié à cet âge-là ça fait
très longtemps que vous occupez
d'adolescents on regarde votre parcours
[Musique]
Philippe Duverger et professeur des
universités praticiens hospitaliers et
chef du service psychiatrie de l'enfant
et de l'adolescent au CHU d'Angers
depuis 20 ans il est l'auteur de
plusieurs ouvrages sur l'enfance et
l'adolescence dont le dernier qui
s'intitule l'amitié à l'adolescence à la
découverte de soi aux éditions First il
témoigne de cas d'adolescents qui
viennent de vivre la crise sanitaire et
où les liens d'amitié ont justement été
malmenés
[Musique]
donc vous avez dédié votre vie
professionnelle aux ados vous continuez
de les recevoir de plus en plus nombreux
versets c'est tangible c'est évident
pour vous qui êtes chef du service on a
des augmentations très importantes
d'admission de jeunes qui auparavant
présenté pas forcément de maladie ou de
pathologies particulières mais qui vont
décompenser à l'occasion de la crise
sanitaire sur des formes qu'on décrira
mais de grandes détresse les compensées
ça veut dire que alors que tout allait
bien tout d'un coup il y a un
effondrement il y a quelque chose qui ne
tient plus et
exactement il craque et donc il déboule
en urgence et aux urgences pour des
scarifications des phobies scolaires des
troubles des conduites alimentaires et
surtout aussi beaucoup des idées
suicidaires mais alors ces
contre-intuitif professeurs parce qu'on
aurait pu se dire précisément que le
retour à la normale fait baisser la
tension c'est ce qu'on espérait nous
aussi oui malheureusement il n'y arrive
pas il ne parviennent pas à retourner à
l'école ne parviennent pas à retrouver
je dirais une vie normale on va
s'arrêter aussi sur le fait qu'ils ont
un cerveau qui évoluent qui est
travaillé parce que effectivement il
n'est pas totalement stabilisé on peut
le dire comme ça regardez cette
infographie
[Musique]
le cerveau des adolescents se développe
de l'arrière vers l'avant la zone du
cerveau qui gère les émotions le système
limbique se développe très vite par
contre la zone qui régule le
comportement et la capacité à prendre
des décisions le cortex préfrontal mûrit
plus tardivement même si dès 6 ans le
cerveau fait déjà 95% de sa taille
adulte il n'est considéré comme étant
mur que vers la fin de la vingtaine les
adolescents traitent plutôt les
informations avec l'amygdale qui fait
partie du système limbique par
conséquent les adolescents peuvent avoir
des émotions profondes et complexes mais
sans pouvoir les contrôler totalement
leur neurones sont aussi très sensibles
à la dopamine l'hormone du plaisir ce
qui peut les pousser à prendre des
risques et à être impulsifs finalement
un grand ménage a lieu dans tout le
cerveau à l'adolescence c'est l'élagage
synaptique les connexions peu utilisées
vont disparaître pour laisser place à de
nouveaux apprentissages comme la
pratique d'un sport d'instruments de
musique ou de nouvelles langues
un adolescent va pouvoir exploiter au
maximum la plasticité de son cerveau
mais ce processus se fait principalement
au repos finalement un ado qui dort est
un ado en pleine forme
[Musique]
ce qu'on comprend à travers
l'infographie professeur c'est que
évidemment la fragilité du cerveau de la
dose est supérieur à celle de l'adulte
on peut le dire comme ça on peut dire en
tous les cas qu'il y a une vulnérabilité
oui que le cerveau de l'adolescent il
est pas terminé tout ce qui est contrôle
des émotions tout ce qui est contrôle de
l'impulsivité qui est beaucoup moins
stabilisée et ça c'est lié l'état de
développement du cerveau exactement avec
un développement des Synaps avec un
développement des connexions cérébrales
qui qui
évolue au cours de l'adolescence ça se
voit d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on appelle
d'ailleurs communément la crise de
l'adolescence l'impulsivité les crises
d'humeur tout ça c'est lié à ce cerveau
qui est en train de se construire
exactement c'est passionnant vous me
disiez tout à l'heure que vous avez noté
donc une augmentation des adolescents
qui viennent aux urgences et qui
viennent aussi dans votre service vous
avez 18 lits ils sont occupés
des huili qui concernent aussi bien la
chirurgie la médecine et la psychiatrie
pour les adolescents au CHU Angers et
ces 18 lits à certains moments sont
occupés pour 100% des cas par des
problématiques psychologiques ou
psychiatriques ah oui c'est nouveau on
avait toujours on a toujours en moyenne
la moitié 50 à 60 % des lits qui sont
occupés par des problématiques
psychiques on est allé jusqu'à 100% mais
ça veut dire que vous refusez parfois
des ados qui vous appellent oui
je dirais que alors évidemment on a ce
biais de sélection qui fait qu'on ne
voit que ceux qui vont le plus mal mais
il y en a beaucoup qui nécessiteraient
des soins et qui et qui sont différés
parce que parce qu'on peut pas répondre
à toutes les demandes alors vous avez
dit le mot phobie scolaire on a voulu
grâce à Sébastien Avila allez voir
comment ça se passait là où évidemment
les enseignants sont en première ligne
pour détecter cette pathologie Sébastien
est allé au déjà Chartres de Bretagne en
banlieue de Rennes on regarde on se
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
on arrive au collège de Chartres de
Bretagne
qui accueille environ 600 élèves et dans
lequel j'effectue une permanence tous
les jeudis une permanence qui existe
depuis
avec un objectif apporter une aide
psychologique au collège tu peux
t'installer chaque semaine ils sont une
petite dizaine à aux affranchir la porte
de son bureau souvent l'entretien
commence de manière informelle autour
d'une question plutôt classique
l'orientation professionnelle alors je
t'écoute pourquoi tu as voulu venir
aujourd'hui
c'était pour parler de mon orientation
même si j'ai déjà une petite idée de
faire de ce que j'aimerais aller
rapidement la conversation devient plus
personnelle plus intime
j'aime pas les cours et du coup ça me
stresse et alors comment ça se manifeste
ce stress je fais souvent des crises
d'angoisse le soir ça m'empêche pas
d'aller en cours parce qu'on a pas le
choix d'y aller mais oui enfin j'ai
pas envie d'y aller pour des
collégiennes comme Jeanne Le covid a été
un soulagement plus qu'une angoisse il
s'est bien passé parce que j'étais chez
moi du coup et j'étais pas au collège
donc c'était c'était mieux pour moi je
restais dans ma chambre donc moi je l'ai
très bien vécu du coup parce que je
sortais pas même si parfois c'était un
petit peu compliqué de pas voir mes
grands-parents ma cousine tout ça moi je
l'ai bien vécu c'est éloignement de
l'école a donc été pour certains élèves
bien vécus mais en contrepartie il a
aussi favorisé le développement de la
phobie scolaire les élèves qui avaient
peut-être pour qui c'était plus
difficile de venir à l'école le fait
d'être resté quelques semaines
sans lien social sans contrainte horaire
sans contrainte scolaire
ont plus de mal à revenir à l'école et à
s'engager
une phobie scolaire qui est prise au
sérieux par l'équipe pédagogique chaque
semaine la directrice de l'établissement
supervise un point de situation sur
l'état d'esprit des collégiens on va
pouvoir commencer la troisième cts
commission technique de suivi de nos
élèves du collège première indicateur
inquiétant l'absentéisme qui augmente
chez certains élèves donc ce jeune
cumulent
98 heures d'absence depuis la rentrée il
vient pas une demi-journée il revient
l'après-midi voilà scolairement c'est
très très fragile et là il décroche
gentiment quoi son professeur de
mathématiques qui m'a interpellé et elle
se demandait si justement il avait une
prise en charge psychologique il a eu un
suivi psy pendant des années et qui a
été arrêté à la demande du jeune mais on
va pouvoir reprendre ça avec
l'éducatrice et le papa la détresse
psychologique des adolescents a augmenté
suite au covid un accompagnement médical
plus étendu serait donc bienvenue mais
il existe des réticences
on peut pas le décréter mais on peut le
conseiller très fortement aux parents en
leur expliquant voilà tout le bien que
ça pourra apporter à leur enfant voilà
parce que des fois ils en ont pas
forcément conscience ou alors aller chez
le psy c'est je suis un débile ce qu'on
entend ça des fois donc ça on essaie de
leur expliquer que non bien sûr que non
on peut tous avoir besoin à un moment de
notre vie d'être accompagné d'être aidé
qu'on soit enfant adolescent ou adulte
dans cet établissement l'alternative au
psychologue est tout simplement
l'infirmière
dans les collèges cette professionnelle
de santé est là pour soigner les
blessures physiques mais pas seulement
exemple avec ce jeune de 13 ans qui
cumule inquiétude scolaire et difficulté
familiales
je l'avais mal vécu je me souviens le
fait d'être avec ma famille ça
m'ennuyait beaucoup donc c'était
compliqué
la première approche qu'ils ont ils vont
exprimer
par leur corps par des somatisations des
maux de ventre des maux de tête et petit
à petit quand la confiance commence à se
mettre en place on va réussir à
savoir
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'il est
préoccupe qu'est-ce qu'il est angoisse
selon une étude récente un collégien sur
4 peut être concerné à un moment de sa
vie par une phobie scolaire loin de
soulager les choses le covid a plutôt eu
tendance à les renforcer
[Musique]
alors professeur c'est intéressant de
voir cette jeune fille qui en réalité
elle n'aimait pas l'école avant le
confinement c'est trouver très bien
pendant le confinement évidemment le
retour à normal la cave absolument et
l'angoisse et la panique et c'est
impossible j'ai vu pas mal de jeunes qui
ont des phobies scolaires dire au fond
finalement quel sens à l'école quel sens
pourrait-on ne pas pourrait-on s'en
passer finalement comme s'il y avait un
manque de confiance dans l'école pour
certains et pas forcément une défiance
mais j'y arriverai sans ça et je préfère
grâce au réseau grâce aux je dirais à la
visio etc suivre mes cours à la maison
en tout cas restez tranquille rester à
l'abri du regard des autres il y a
vraiment ce sentiment là de ce de se
protéger du monde qui est angoissant ça
c'est la perte de sens comme on dit
souvent mais parce que ils ont vu qu'on
pouvait faire l'école autrement mais
évidemment et puis que finalement que ça
qu'ils étaient même plutôt mieux dans le
collège c'était intéressant cette
communauté enseignante c'est génial qui
prenait ça en compte il passait des
réunions essayer de détecter c'est
absolument là c'est vrai qu'ils sont en
première ligne l'école fait ça bien je
voudrais qu'on parle parce que vous avez
souhaité poser une question c'est
l'habitude c'est la tradition dans cette
émission on interpelle un parlementaire
sur une interrogation de notre invité et
vous vous avez parlé vous voulez parler
du harcèlement scolaire pourquoi
harcèlement scolaire pourquoi parce que
sur près de 50% des jeunes filles qui
sont hospitalisés dans notre service il
est question de harcèlement scolaire à
un moment donné dans leur parcours et
que c'est vraiment une problématique
dont ces jeunes filles vont parfois
avoir du mal à parler et que
l'hospitalisation un moment de
révélation et que moi je voyais pas ça
il y a une vingtaine d'années qu'est-ce
qui fait que ça devient du harcèlement
au point de déclencher éventuellement
des des malaises psychologiques
grave qui peut aller jusqu'au suicide
c'est pour ça que je veux en parler mais
ça va être toutes les formes de violence
qu'elles soient verbales qu'elle soit
physique
entre un ado ou plusieurs contre un
autre ado avec l'idée en plus notamment
sous les formes du cyber-harcèlement
qu'elles vont être
loin du regard des adultes et souvent 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 et donc la
question que vous posez c'est évidemment
de savoir comment ça peut être davantage
pris en charge détecter la question est
posée à Erwan Malan qui est un député
MoDem du Finistère qui lui-même avait
proposé cette année une loi pour rendre
le harcèlement un délit enfin pour le
faire passer en délit et punir
d'ailleurs d'emprisonnement les
responsables lorsque les victimes sont
poussées au suicide en écoute la réponse
à votre question
[Musique]
dans le cadre de la loi sur le
harcèlement scolaire cette loi il y
avait trois piliers il y avait le pilier
prévention le pilier accompagnement et
le pilier protection et la prévention
c'est tout simplement une obligation qui
est maintenant inscrite dans la loi de
pour chaque établissement scolaire qui
soit privé publique hors contrat sous
contrat l'obligation d'avoir un plan de
prévention et un plan de résolution des
conflits autour du harcèlement scolaire
l'éducation nationale il y a un
programme phare qui a un très bon
programme avec une méthode qui est la
méthode de la préoccupation partagée qui
est une très bonne méthode aussi de de
prévention et de résolution des conflits
quand ils sont pas trop graves il faut
toujours éviter de les conflits soient
graves en cas de harcèlement scolaire
c'est là que ça devient terrible pour
les enfants pour les familles et pour et
pour la société
[Musique]
et donc professeur cette idée que les
écoles sont sensibilisées finalement la
détection du harcèlement scolaire c'est
un début de réponse de sensibilisation
de de savoir que ça existe d'être
attentif d'essayer de repérer le plus
tôt possible et puis d'accompagner bien
évidemment les jeunes qui sont harcelés
et puis de prendre aussi et
d'accompagner les harceleurs qui souvent
d'ailleurs vont pas forcément beaucoup
mieux j'aimerais qu'on s'arrête quand
même sur la question des écrans
parce que évidemment pendant le covid il
y a eu moins d'interactions physiques et
tous les élèves étaient devant des
écrans est-ce que l'écran est un facteur
d'aggravation de l'état psychologique
des ados je crois que c'est c'est une
fausse piste que de les diaboliser
en revanche il faut sûrement se rendre
compte que que ils y sont pour quelque
chose je pense qu'il y a c'est mon point
de vue une certaine déshumanisation je
le dis comme ça de toutes les relations
qui vont passer par les écrans avec que
on l'a vu des addictions très très
importantes c'est-à-dire qui savent plus
s'en passer il y a une injonction
à être collée à son écran oui mais les
adultes aussi d'ailleurs maintenant ils
sont bien sûr c'est bien le paradoxe
c'est-à-dire que j'ai vu moi pendant le
confinement des pères des mères en
télétravail à la maison devant leur
écran toute la journée dire à leur ado
dans la chambre à côté arrête avec tes
écrans mais alors comment on fait vous
quand vous les hospitalisez vous leur
confisquer le portable alors nous depuis
15 ans on a un règlement dans le service
qui est que les adolescents ont le droit
à leur smartphone leur portable que deux
fois une demi-heure une demi-heure le
matin une demi-heure le soir c'est pas
beaucoup par rapport au 24 heures quand
on leur annonce complètement mais sidéré
en disant mais ça va pas être possible
et pendant qu'en effet ils ne l'ont pas
il est sous clé dans le salle de soins
des infirmières ils n'ont pas accès du
tout une demi-heure le matin une
demi-heure le soir mais on propose des
choses à la place c'est à dire qu'en
effet si on ne fait que leur supprimer
en leur proposant rien d'autre ils vont
s'ennuyer à quoi ils vont penser aux
écrans donc on fait plein de choses avec
eux des consultations des soins
médiatisés etc et depuis 15 ans aucun ne
s'est plaint peut-être même que certains
ont pu vous dire soulage docteur ça m'a
fait du bien merci moins dépendant
absolument ils sont soulagés ils sont
apaisés c'est pour ça que je parle de
tyrannie d'injonction alors on a
souhaité rencontrer des jeunes gens qui
se font utiliser Sébastien villa est
allé à l'Institut MGEN de la verrière
service psychiatrique pour adolescent
précisément rencontré une jeune patiente
en difficulté ça fait deux ans qu'elle
subit des difficultés graves et elle a
accepté dans témoigner reportages
[Musique]
jamais dans son histoire le service
psychologique de cet établissement n'a
autant accueilli de jeunes
[Musique]
de plus en plus nombreux ils viennent
ici pour tenter d'apaiser des
souffrances psychiques qui prennent
différentes formes je souhaiterais
savoir
où vous en êtes vous de la compréhension
de vos troubles de vos souffrances c'est
l'anorexie mentale que j'ai depuis
quelques années maintenant elle a été
diagnostiquée au bout de quelques mois
les difficultés c'est tout ce qui est en
rapport justement avec la maladie donc
tout ce qui peut être l'alimentation le
poids
l'anorexie de clara est une conséquence
inattendue du covid sans activité
physique elle s'est inquiétée d'une
menace potentielle on fait ce qu'on a
appelé l'épidémie d'obésité
qui est ça c'est des choses qui m'ont
fait super peur parce que je me suis dit
c'est vrai je bouge plus
on continue à manger donc pourquoi je
reste une jeune fille mince alors que on
a tout arrêté anorexie scarification
trouble du sommeil les manifestations
d'angoisse sont diverses et plus
compliquées à prendre en charge pour les
équipes médicales bien on va s'arrêter
là pour aujourd'hui à la semaine
prochaine la semaine prochaine merci au
revoir bonne journée merci vous aussi
d'hospitalisation plus longue mais avec
des rechutes il y a des sorties des
rechutes des entrées puis des
hospitalisations
et puis aussi des symptômes qui
s'inscrivent qui se chronicise en fait
le covid nous a montrés comme ça des
adolescents qui peut-être n'auraient pas
décompensé
s'il y avait pas eu ce moment un peu
hors temps un peu orlyeux qui a été le
confinement pour constater
l'augmentation des cas regarder ce
baromètre de la santé mentale l'année
2022 a vu une forte hausse des passages
aux urgences pour aider suicidaires chez
les 15 17 ans les tentatives de suicide
quant à elle ont presque doublé une
explosion des détestes sans que pour
autant les moyens suivent il est évident
que c'est extrêmement difficile et
notamment je pense au Secrétaire médical
de recevoir des appels et de devoir dire
bah non non on n'a pas de place on est
plein on a une très grande difficulté
à recruter des temps médicaux des temps
infirmiers on a des carences de poste
et donc on ferme des délits en fait donc
on a même moins de lit qu'avant
alors les équipes des soignants font le
mieux qu'elles peuvent tentant par tous
les moyens de libérer la parole
Clara je vous ai mis quelques photos
donc comme d'habitude on va se poser
quelques minutes on choisit deux photos
et c'est de me raconter une histoire ça
vous va et moi je vais essayer de faire
pareil du coup une discussion autour des
enjeux climatiques nouvelles sources
d'inquiétude d'un monde décidément de
plus en plus incertain
ok la tortue
quelque chose vous interpelle par ces
images cette image ici elle fait penser
à l'eau assez pure et je trouve qu'il y
a vraiment un lien parce que sur l'autre
photo bah c'est comme en fait c'est
comme si il y avait plus de sécheresse
est-ce que ça vous interpelle au niveau
de la thématique par exemple vous me dit
sécheresse là il y a beaucoup d'eau à
quoi ça peut vous faire penser tout ça
bah la sécheresse c'est quelque chose
que c'est un sujet qu'on aborde beaucoup
en ce moment avec le réchauffement
climatique et
et donc oui je trouve qu'il y a une
photographie
qui peut être plus inquiétante par
rapport à l'actualité
aujourd'hui Clara est en bonne voie pour
gagner son combat contre la maladie
mais ces craintes en l'avenir n'ont pas
disparu pour autant et malheureusement
elle fragilise peut-être sa guérison
[Musique]
professeur question au passage de
reportage
que des jeunes filles bon les jeunes
filles sont plus fragiles
en tout cas les jeunes filles
n'expriment pas forcément
la souffrance de la même manière que les
garçons on constate exactement la même
chose dans notre service puisque 82 %
des jeunes hospitalisés pour des raisons
psy sont des jeunes filles 82%
considère je pense malgré tout que les
jeunes filles sont plus aptes à décrire
évoquer leur souffrance ou leur mal-être
les garçons en revanche eux vont être
plutôt dans des passages en force ça
passe ou ça casse par exemple les
tentatives de suicide trois quarts des
tentatives de suicide trois quarts ce
sont des jeunes filles ce sont des
intoxications médicamenteuses alors ça
c'est statistique absolument trois
quarts des tentatives de suicide ce sont
des jeunes filles c'est pour ça qu'on
les voit à l'hôpital en revanche trois
quarts des suicides ce sont des garçons
sur la totalité absolument des
adolescents trois quarts des suicides ce
sont des garçons les garçons ils se
loupent pas pour le dire autrement et et
les jeunes filles vont le dire vont
l'exprimer vont l'écrire vont laisser
des lettres vont écarter les mers ce que
vont pas faire les garçons comment faire
pour aider ces garçons mais je crois
qu'il faut les faut être attentifs faut
accepter l'idée qu'un garçon ça peut
être fragile
ont du mal aussi à projeter cette
formation et peut-être qu'en effet on
veut pas regarder la fragilité du garçon
je crois que les pères ont fait beaucoup
de progrès il pourrait en faire un petit
peu plus pour s'occuper de leur fiston
ou de s'occuper des garçons c'est
souvent les mères qui accompagnent les
ados aux urgences
je pense que les pères pourraient pour
être plus présent vous avez dit en
discuter un peu avant l'émission et vous
m'avez fait vous m'avez dit cette cette
constat vous avez fait ce constat on
n'écoute pas assez les ados on les
écoute pas on leur demande et la crise
sanitaire a été très importante on leur
demande de mettre des masques de de
enfin toutes les gestes barrières etc
mais mais jamais on a demandé leur avis
jamais on a sollicité finalement le
regard par rapport à ça et on les écoute
pas sur l'avenir alors ils essayent avec
le climat avec les autres crises qui
nous entourent de de s'engager justement
et de se faire entendre mais mais on les
écoute pas assez et qu'est-ce qu'ils
sont heureux dans les consultations
quand on leur laisse le temps de dire
d'exprimer de construire l'avenir on a
trop peur à la place de projette nos
propres angoisses sur eux plutôt que
d'écouter comment eux ils pourraient
construire leur projet leur avenir leur
façon de voir il faut leur faire
confiance
beaucoup beaucoup
ils ont une créativité ils ont une façon
parfois d'inventer des choses de de
percevoir des choses à condition
évidemment de les écouter pour finir
quel est votre un de vos plus beaux
souvenirs avec un adolescent vous avez
eu dans votre service peut-être parmi
les plus beaux souvenirs que je peux
avoir c'est finalement
quelques années après des suivis de
m'apercevoir que il s'est passé quelque
chose entre nous qui se rappelle que
finalement un moment donné ils allaient
pas bien qui a une vraie rencontre à ce
moment-là avec eux qui leur a permis de
se soulager de trouver des solutions et
qu'il souhaite à ce moment-là en
témoigner des années après et je dirais
c'est très émouvant en tous les cas
parce qu'on a l'impression d'avoir
je dirais pas influer le destin
influencer les choses mais être là à un
moment donné qui leur a permis de
repartir et ça à ce moment-là on a on se
dit qu'on a fait peut-être quelque chose
de pas si mal c'est une sacrée
gratification merci beaucoup professeur
du verger d'avant été l'invité d'état de
santé merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
à très vite pour un prochain numéro
[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance vous
a présenté état de santé
[Musique]